good afternoon everybody bonjour
thank you for joining us for this media
availability within term chief bell
joining us are deputy commissioner
chris harkins from the opp and rcmp
deputy commissioner mike zum federal
policing
and i will be the moderator we will be
we will begin with remarks from interim
chief bell and then we will proceed to a
10 to 15 minute question period
we're here to provide you today with an
update on our operations to end the
unlawful protests that we've done so
much damage to our community and so much
harm to our residents the operational
plan is moving ahead as we expected and
the contingencies we put in place are
effectively dealing with the threats
we're seeing on the ground
i thank the ottawa residents for their
patience and support as they watch this
operation unfold
i also thank thank all the planners
officers and emergency personnel many of
whom have come from across the country
to assist us
i'm proud to work with all of them their
assistance has been vital to the success
we are seeing so far in this operation
we're in control of the situation on the
ground and continue to push forward to
clear our streets
this methodical and well-resourced plan
will take time and we are here to see it
through to a safe ending
last night we began to take additional
actions towards implementing our
operation
we moved officers and equipment into key
positions throughout the city and took
up 100 checkpoints around the downtown
core
we began making arrests of key
individuals who were responsible for
organizing these unlawful activities
this morning public order units and a
significant number of officers were
deployed to support our operations
we first focused on nikola on the
nicholas street area where unlawful
protests were gathered with trucks
even this morning all unlawful
lawful protesters were given many many
opportunities to leave
officers then turned to the intersection
of rito and sussex making more arrests
and clearing that location as of 3 pm
today we've arrested 70 people they have
been charged with a mult with multiple
various offenses including mischief
work is underway by the city of ottawa
to remediate and clean up the area that
we've gained back today
we also saw children that were present
in the area we've prepared prepared for
this and have plans to ensure that these
children are unharmed during our
operation
before i take questions i want to
acknowledge that these are not the
images that ottawa residents want to see
ottawa is a welcoming and diverse city
it's a city we're all proud of
we regularly host lawful and peaceful
protests this is family day weekend and
usually our downtown is filled with
people enjoying the city our market and
the canal
we focus we're focused on returning our
city to the place that we all know and
love
we will run this operation 24 hours a
day until the residents and community
have their entire city city back
thank you and i'm happy to take any
name and questions and you have one
question with a follow-up question thank
you joanne tinello cbc news um hi
cheekbell um
you know i was out at mckenzie avenue
and
rito and
many officers of many uh units are out
there holding the line there sort of
pushing
the folks westbound i guess on
wellington um it's getting to be late in
the afternoon and i'm just wondering as
much as you can can you tell us what the
plan is now when i was there anyway for
about an hour everyone was sort of just
standing still uh more or less um
obviously people like to know how long
this would take i don't know if you can
say that but maybe if you can say about
what might happen overnight uh and what
the next steps are thank you
so we we have articulated from the very
beginning we have a very deliberate and
methodical plan that's been extremely
well resourced
i want to thank commissioner karik
commissioner lucky every police chief
across this across canada every police
chief in ontario who have dedicated
resource to help us staff the plan and
see all the officers that you're seeing
today
we from the beginning have indicated
that we would need to move slowly safely
respecting charter rights as we look to
demobilize this demonstration we will
continue to do that and we will work day
and night until this is completed
and just as a follow-up maybe you could
talk a little bit about the kind of
resistance you're seeing is it mostly
peaceful is it obviously the rest of 70
people so
perhaps not but perhaps you could
describe what it's been like for
officers out there and what they're
finding as they meet the protesters
so uh the officers out there
i know everyone's seen many images
through the day have been nothing short
of exceptionally professional all day we
have a plan we articulated that plan to
them and they have executed it extremely
well throughout the day
the level of professionalism that
they're seeing in the face of taunts
slurs towards them is
is challenging but we're seeing their
ongoing professionalism every minute of
every day we'll continue to do that our
officers will continue to work
exceptionally hard to make sure that we
use the least amount of force needed to
actually peacefully end this protest and
move everyone out of our streets
all right chief bill john millen with
the citizen have officers had to help
children's aid remove any children from
families at this point
so we spoke yesterday about the fact we
did have plans
and we're working continually with
children's aid around safety and
security of children in the crowds
we developed those plants hoping that we
weren't going to have to use them
i can tell you to this point we have had
no need to interact with children's aid
as it relates to children within the
crowd what i will tell you is that even
through all the planning it still shocks
and surprises me that we are seeing
children put in harm's way in the middle
of a demonstration where a police
operation is unfolding we will continue
to look after their safety and security
but we implore all the parents who have
kids in there get kids out of there they
do not need to be in the middle of this
it is not a safe place for them chief
what we see downtown right now is do you
expect this to be the posture going
right through the long weekend
as i indicated we will we've started
this operation we talked about uh our
increasing plans yesterday in terms of
securing the downtown core we have a
plan it's well resourced and we will
continue to execute on that plan until
everyone is gone from our streets and
the residents that own those streets get
them back
mario from the canadian press we've seen
um forces from quebec from durham down
there on the front line i'm sorry i'm
sorry i can't hear you thank you mary
wolf from the canadian press
um
there are police officers from quebec
durham various forces down there on the
front line can you give us an idea of
how many police officers are being
mobilized in this operation
so we won't be disclosing any of our
operational numbers but but i'll again
point back to the level of cooperation
and partnership we've had with every
police service every law enforcement
agency across canada unparalleled and
absolutely amazing i'm very proud of how
our community of how our police agencies
and how all other support services have
come together to mobilize to end this
unlawful demonstration
and i noticed that some of the police
from quebec have tear gas are you
prepared to use tear gas and is that a
last resort
so we've developed a well articulated
plan we continue to work with the
protesters the demonstrators to
encourage them to leave the area we have
a very well scripted warning that's
provided to them and up in
every moment that they can leave there
afforded the opportunity to leave we
have well developed plans that will
ensure
ultimate removal of those protesters
from our streets
hi there chris nashgate ctv national
news my first question is did police use
any of the powers confirmed under the
emergencies act to make any arrests
today or did you use the powers of
existing law in the ontario state of
emergency
so i could tell you the
the three levels of government that have
come together to support our efforts in
this um have led us to be able to have
the success we're starting to see right
now uh the emergency measures act uh the
provincial emergency act as well as the
city of ottawa emergency and injunction
that have been have been provided have
created the ability for us to
use powers and use new and
new and existing powers to be able to
properly deal with the demonstration to
ultimately bring it to an end without
the authorities that have been provided
to us through these pieces of
legislation we wouldn't be able to be
doing the work we are today
my other question here is you talked
about the arrests thank you for that um
but
during the live video today on ctv news
channel we saw
in between when there was the hold the
line issue there between the protesters
and the police there was some hitting
amongst one another was there any
injuries
are you reporting any injuries right now
from police and protesters so i can tell
you we have no injuries from the
protester we have one injury to
one of the members of the police team it
was a minor injury that has been treated
here with an extra question but i'm just
wondering if we have an update on or an
estimate as to how many protesters are
actually still here it's mixed in with
media it's kind of hard to tell is there
any update you can give us on that so
again we're not providing numbers a
number of people present number of
operational resources we're using as we
move ahead
protesters yeah no we're not providing
any of those numbers
okay
thank
thank
you
very
much